édouard precision thank you you look
beautiful as always
do you know that you were my first crush
you were my first crush too
don't do this he's too weak for you the
things you love about him now are the
things you'll hate I really wanted to be
this person that you thought I was when
you love someone you have to be careful
with it you might never get it again my
ex-husband used to call me a nocturnal
animal I didn't know you had an
ex-husband did you love him I did
something horrible to him I left him in
a brutal way
are we gonna do it's a question of how
serious you are about seeing justice
stuff you're crazy
making a big thing
I'm gonna live to regret this he's gonna
be rough for him out there not knowing
how it's gonna come nobody is away with
what you did not buddy
[Music]
[Music]
do you ever feel like your life has
turned into something you never intended
[Music]
I'm worried about you are you sleeping
you scared me the last time we talked
you know me I never sleep my ex-husband
used to call me and nocturnal animal I
didn't know you had an ex-husband I've
been thinking about him a lot lately
then recently he sent me this book that
he's written it's violent and then sad
and he dedicated it to me did you love
him I did something horrible to him
[Music]
are we gonna do it's a question of how
serious you are about seeing justice
done talk to this you'll regret it
[Music]
I really wanted to be this person that
you thought I was
you're crazy like I'm being saying
you'll never find out
when you love someone you have to be
careful with it you might never get it
again
it's fun to kill big boat we should try
it sound 10 nobody is away with what you
did
[Music]
nobody
you